foreign
[Music]
let's talk about designing a socially
critical data science course
I have for you a play in three Acts
Act One teaching about wealth inequality
act two data analysis for Social Action
and act three specific resources to help
you teach
here's act one
welcome to your first day of my class
the very first thing we do
is that everyone gets one penny
an actual physical penny
the very next thing that we do is offer
a prediction about the following
everyone's going to do one trade with a
classmate
with your penny
how do you trade you find another
student
you bet against them on a random outcome
event like a coin flip or rock paper
scissors
and the loser pays the winner one penny
here's an abstract view of what my
classroom would look like
two students would find each other and
pair up
there's one penny at stake
they're gonna
compete on a random outcome event and
bet on the odds and the loser is going
to pay the winner one penny
so this happens across the classroom
simultaneously with different students
in different pairs
before trading were all equal
if you were to look at a bar graph of
everybody's wealth it looks really
uninteresting everybody's got one unit
of many it's a penny and we've ordered
these uh completely randomly but um
uh each agent as it were has a bar
so the first question I asked before we
even do the trade is what's going to
happen after everyone does one trade
I'd like you to imagine that
you each have a penny
you're going to match up with somebody
else
you're going to bet on something a coin
flip is pretty handy because you both
have pennies
and the loser is going to pay the winner
one penny
so what happens after that happens
is that half the people in the room go
broke
and half the people in the room double
their money
instantly with one trade
then you ask what happens after lots of
Trades
that starts to look like this where you
can see that um
a few people have most of the wealth
and there's even one person who's got
five pennies which means they quintuple
their initial investment
but
71 percent of the people in this
simulation are broke
not poor not impoverished
broke
here's another case of us running it
with slightly different rules and a
greater money supply
I like this one a lot it shows the same
features we have a few people with most
of the wealth
but then you have
people who go below the zero line
with negative 20 wealth that they
finished with and you might be saying to
yourself is that an error in the graph
or what happened
loans happened
we allowed students to loan money at
interest so they could loan four pennies
with the expectation of getting five
back I think was the rule for that
simulation
and the very first outcome was that the
students constructed their own subprime
loan crisis
nobody was checking credit so I watched
one student hit the same person up for
like five loans and when she denied him
a sixth loan he walked across the
classroom
found somebody else who didn't know him
and got more loans
the second outcome is that the students
discovered the value of a distribution
graph
so these bar graphs have the advantage
of Simplicity but every time we run the
simulation we can't predict who's going
to get most of the money we just know
that it's going to concentrate
and I do this on purpose because I want
them to see that it's very difficult to
predict the outcome of a bar graph
but if there's some underlying property
that says oh most of the money is going
to go to the few that's the value of a
distribution graph that one distribution
graph can represent so many different
situations
so ultimately we can't predict which
agents will go broke but we can predict
that most will
finally I think it's important that a
seemingly Fair system can still produce
unfair results
it seems fair because the coin toss is
fair and everybody has an equal shot but
it's not fair because broke people
routinely get denied the opportunity to
trade again
if you had money why would you trade
with a broke person
you have a 50 chance of losing some
money and a 50 chance of getting no
money
that's it
so broke people stay broke and they stay
out of the simulation ultimately
here's act two data analysis for Social
Action
so when I was teaching at Michigan State
a very local crisis was getting
International attention and it had to do
with the poisoning of the water supply
in Flint Michigan Flint's about an hour
away from East Lansing which where I was
teaching
um
the super short version is that to save
money the city of Flint decided to stop
importing water from the great lakes and
divert the Flint River instead and the
Flint River's toxic corrosiveness
leached lead out of the pipes
this was happening while we were
teaching the course and a data set had
just come out from Folks at Virginia
Tech who had sent at home testing kits
to 270 families in Flint
to
get readings on their water levels
and we had students analyze this and
write about it
here's one example of a student analysis
where what they've done is try to
compute the number of samples that
exceed the epa's action limit
so the EPA says if more than 10 of your
samples are above this threshold which
happens to be 0.015 milligrams per liter
I think
um you've got a problem
and a student wrote some code to count
up how many of the raw samples there are
that exceed that amount as well as the
percentage that exceed that amount
the other thing I want to point out to
you is it's difficult to see perhaps but
that distribution has a real long tail
and there are some folks out there at
0.2 or yeah uh point Sorry 0.12 0.14
six eight times the legal limit for lead
that's a huge problem
so we had our students write to the
governor of Michigan
with their analysis results and here's
an example student one I constructed a
histogram I also wrote a simple program
to compute the number of samples and the
percentage above the limit
45 samples exceeded the EPA limit making
this 16.6 percent of the samples above
the action limit
this indicates the seriousness of this
problem and exactly why we need to
urgently take action to help Flint
act three resources to help you teach
you might be asking what can I do
so I have three pieces of advice that
I'm going to go into detail on
the first is try to choose data and
activities that question systems of
power
the second is do what you can to make
bias issues in your data known
and check for them
and the third which I think is arguably
the most important is to adopt a
critical framework to analyze and expose
oppression
so first up you should use the
opportunity of being able to choose data
sets for your class to analyze to ask
what issues demand our attention
socially
now I don't want to stand here and say
that every activity that you do must
always be focused on improving the
social good but I think even if you
started with one activity you'd find it
has a ripple impact and it gets you
thinking about more data that can do
this and it gets your students thinking
about more ways they can try and help
Society through the Newfound Powers
they're learning in your courses
second you can check data for biases you
can ask who is being disadvantaged in
this data
and so
um
a tool for that is IBM's AI 360. I've
got the link down there but also I'll
have a QR code you can scan which has
all the links that are related to this
presentation so don't panic
um the AI fairness 360 has some demo
data that you can take a look at and
this is an example of what it can
produce for you this data was analyzed
and has a privileged Group which
happened to be females and an
unprivileged Group which happened to be
males because we have representational
issues of unequal waiting
so the tool goes on to determine things
like what would the statistical parity
difference be what's the Equal
Opportunity difference what's the
average odds difference
and then
it goes so far as to offer strategies
for addressing that bias
um
these are two of the automated
strategies that it proposes re-waiting
and optimized pre-processing I think a
third is adversarial learning but I
don't know that much about adversarial
learning so don't quote me on that
um but the idea is that the tool lets
you see where your data might be leading
you to conclusions that are steered by
biases that in most cases we want to
correct for
and it offers automated solutions for
doing so
my third point is about adopting a
critical framework
I think it's so important to recognize
that data analyzes are not value neutral
so this is a book called Data feminism
that came out in 2020 from MIT press you
can read the entire thing for free at
their website which again will be in my
list of links in my QR code thing
here's a quote from a description of the
book
illustrating data feminism in action dig
nazio and Klein show how challenges to
the male female binary can help
challenge other hierarchical and
empirically wrong classification systems
it's a little dargony
so let's do this
raise your hand if you've either seen or
yourself done gender as a dichotomous
variable
zero or one
right so what happens when your gender
is not captured by zero or one or male
or female well you could add another
option like
non-gender conforming but what happens
if your gender is just non-binary or
your gender is gender fluid
you could add options till the cows come
home really what's being revealed to you
is an oppressive system
that
um is forcing people into categories
that they don't necessarily identify
with
or is forcing them to exclude themselves
from the data analysis entirely just by
not answering the question
and Ignacio and Klein are trying to
point out it's stuff like that that we
might not even be consciously aware of
if we're not thinking for it that can
have huge impacts on the people we're
asking questions of
my final example comes from mapping
Detroit
um I call this redlining in action
this was a map that was produced in 1929
by an all-white all-male Chamber of
Commerce and a majority white male
Federal home loan board
the purpose of the map was to figure out
neighborhoods where it was risky to
offer people loans and neighborhoods
where it was safe to offer people loans
the effect of the map is that an already
racially segregated demographic
is now disproportionately affected by
people's decisions not to lend to for
example
black people
because
sorry excuse me because
those were deemed neighborhoods where it
was risky to lend so can you imagine if
your credit worthiness depended not on
yourself but on who's next to you
imagine how that crushes social Mobility
imagine how that reifies social order
Ignacio and Klein say early 20th century
redlining Maps had an aura very similar
to The Big Data approaches of today
these high-tech scalable Solutions were
deployed Across the Nation and there
were one method among many that worked
to ensure that wealth remained attached
to the racial category of whiteness
that wealth remained attached to the
racial category of whiteness
I think it's worth asking if that's what
data science was doing then
what's it doing now
thanks folks
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]